alrighty team it's finally here March of
the machines release weekend or
pre-release weekend I should say and
what a fantastic week
I've decided to grab some collector
boosters
so
let's jump into it
hope you guys have all had a fantastic
pre-release weekend have got all the
things that you want to open
pack one
let's go
grab night for our uh EDH deck that
we're no doubt gonna build
Halo Forger
forager
got a awesome battle here
invasion of dominaria
obviously foil both sides
gorgeous gorgeous frexian
uh land there
and oh what a start omnath locus of all
this is also the buyer box promo
yes nice city on fire can't wait to
Chuck this in a commander deck
we've got
authion hero of lava Brink
this is one of our what do they call the
mythical Legends rave
master smith
chasing a Ragga van oh wow
jury Master look at that foiling it's
like the um
the the foiling from the Warhammer 40K
decks
and Lilia liliana's Talent this is I
think
I think so they released five Talent
cards I'm pretty sure this is the best
one Nick this interfere are the best one
such a good what a great pack and we've
got fire song Sun speaker as the other
hero card although there's a bit of
blurring
I don't know if the camera picks it up
there's a bit of blurring on the camera
there but that is gorgeous
and
token
what a great first pack there
let's quickly
lay those out fire song Juliana
oh City on fire on there yeah what a
great pack
all right let's keep going
oh very cool we got the
new incubator tokens
really like those
so far Axion Gargantua
too weird
again really nice for that land
glistening Dawn is our first rare here
rampaging Raptor
full
lock Wayne Lancer this is in the night
sorry this is in the night pre-con
radar Coalition Warlord
and
emot celibate or bounty we didn't get
the nice
um
Animal Care aren't there oh and they're
another foil blood feather Phoenix
oh nice Emery lurker of the lock what
okay this is the best card in the pack
100 gorgeous not unfortunately not
serialized
chair we didn't get I didn't
accidentally get a serialized card in
the other packs there I don't think so
all right we can sort those out later
next pack
so obviously we want serialized ragavan
that's the dream serialized rank event
serialized free tour
why am I struggling with this one
fan player token
nice treasure
okay artistic refusal
blind Reaper valid
Forest
and
oh wow nice croxer and kurinos
oh yes Power Ranger card it's Harley
Primal conqueror and let's just check
the other side of that
this is the 11-11
poison counter
and
path of the amethyst
oh nice Dax sauce blessed by the Sun
Ray Renata called to the hunt
oh nice Inga and asika
that's the
um
caldheim
no is it cow time
I believe that's the cloudheim Border
oh wow look at that
blue tree the spell Chaser unfortunately
abandoned Commander
as as a commander and not played
anywhere else but
love the artwork on that and I think
this is one of the is this the second
this is the first time lootery has been
printed with the proper
uh companion uh rules there as well
nice again
no serialized
I think again on that loot through the
the texting is a bit weird there
Xerox stroganite frexian sensor really
like this card
or wow swamp
Into the Fire
night Aaron of hisos essos EOS
steppen War Riders
think this is in the
backup deck no this is in the gremlin
Gremlin artifact commander deck
foil Inger run eyes
oh nice we gotta look we got a good one
oh tesuko umizawa future fugitive this
goes great in the Dolson deck or
basically any
uh
uh you know defense toughness matters
deck
oh
sick look at that durju and hazrat in
the invocation is it invocation foil uh
bordering
nice that is
that is amazing that's really nice and
our final
squee The Immortal in the glass stained
from dominaria United and
we got a foil rag event
but not not really
is that the closest we're going to get
to the foil rag event
they ask you how you are you just have
to say that you're fine when you're not
really fine but you just can't get into
it because they would never understand
let's keep going we can put this one
here
that is sick
sand stalker Monarch we got
is this like it's only this is only our
Second Battle invasion of kaladesh
again loving these foil Islands
quintaurus lawmaster hashtag spoilers
coming up his spark got uh ignited so
he's likely to be a planeswalker in the
next excellent set
excellent Commander card here as well
cool
nice we got heliod radiant Dawn let's
quickly
I get a look at his other side there
this is obviously the Theros uh
constellation
style here again excellent Commander
card
of the schema
jury we got another one of these second
jury
this is in the uh regular foil ink pad
to
we've got the I think this is the Halo
foiling that's right Halo foiling
Tamara chosen from death
in the Halo foiling as well
thymine Commando
oh wow taser carlov
excellent excellent come on I think this
is one of the best black white
flameswalkers and again in that gorgeous
Halo foiling
awesome awesome
and Elemental
all right pack number six
the regular Island
merciless repurposing our poor boy
urubrask
thankfully though he has the best
Predator I think in this set
nice
invasion of new capena
equipment is actually really good don't
sleep on this equipment
Forest
oh wow invasion of icoria this is I
think the this has got to be top three
battles this is is it green sun Zenith
on a battle and then it let's not spoil
the rest of the pack
transforms into
zil oh my God zilthur
Apex or vicoria
basically oh it makes all your creatures
practically unblockable
Chrome host seed shark
oh spoilers
icor Elixir we've got Dina Soul seeper
this is in the mythical archives from
strix Haven style
we got another jury this is just in the
etched foiling
ancient empirical
lifel the bount bountius dawn
and
Elemental token
okay okay it still doesn't beat the uh
has a rat pack that was pretty sick I
mean pack number one was freaking
awesome as well we got the nearly
everything we wanted in that one pack
another awesome incubate token there
storm claw rager
Scrappy Bruiser
Mountain
Transcendent message excellent excellent
blue card draw especially for the blue
red token deck that I want to build
oh nice uh is this the ink splotch
glissa Herald of predation
full spoilers
path the pyromancer
valderduck Keeper of the flame dominara
United
we've got a etched Dax sauce blessed by
the Sun
C double probably one of the better
Commander cards
oh
Azuri claw of progress in the blood ink
blotched from
or will be one
excellent excellent Commander card
and that wraps up that back
that's really nice put that one there
Johnny getting killed
golden scale aeronaut skip through these
zelfrin Lancer
Kendra spell spear I really like this
card this was a lot of fun to play in
the early access event
videos up soon for that
Island all right here we go
blood feather Phoenix this is our second
one of these oh
Simone and Dina ah yes I wanted this
check out my uh my video on this
Commander this is the deck that I'll be
building
spoilers
fireman Commando
Raph whoever like steward
etched I'm not a fan of this etching
here look how dull that card looks
Tamara chosen from death oh nice we've
got Aura this is one of the other cars
that we wanted fantastic let's do this
quickly not sure if we do have one more
card
look at that
foil great works foil or a brass
absolutely gorgeous
and our final card
Captain lanary storm this girl brass can
go go up here with uh called Warren Plex
up there
oh nice that that's awesome
there he is up there
all right we're we're doing good we're
doing good
let me get these out of the way
okay furnace Reigns
battle invasion of zendikar
planes
Ira Widow of the realm
let's quickly see who she transforms
into Ira the furnace Queen
oh nice I think this is the other Power
Ranger car if you wanted golter and more
even one of the team up cards oh no he
doesn't transform
very cool
oh spoilers prismas he is the face
commander of the forexian commander deck
iagle
with the most dominaria artwork there
have master smith in the etched artwork
glistening Dawn
I haven't got one of these already
Eudora grave Gardener oh my word I
actually want one of these cards as well
this is fantastic this is going right
into my Merkel deck I think
and so good that was a pretty good pack
I'm pretty happy with that can't
complain
last three packs
I think we're doing really well
I thought can I say it was an old card
from zendikar remember it being printed
in this set
on the scene uh storm the seed cord with
Gorgeous art there
herbology instructor
swamp
errant and glider gida guider excellent
in the Angels deck or the blue white
flying deck just in general
oh
pylon
the what Commander's new best removal
spell
come on
Miss winner missed Meadow vanisher I
think this is from the backup
uh commander deck
Finn the Fang Bearer in the awesome
uh it is cow time it is cow time artwork
really really nice
come on Yargo in the etched
roundbreaker The Invasion tree
borderless very nice and oh wow
jingataxis core auger this is in the
again so this is the original Jin
cataxus reprinted uh just in the new ink
splotch artwork you cannot complain
there incubator token of course this one
doesn't transform it's just a regular
card
this very very nice
alrighty down to our uh last couple of
packs here
this can't be the only foil rag event we
get
all right mutagen connoisseur
Wicked slumber
Forest
nice adrana and Luvana
lovana lovan Lin valer words
really nice Commander card here
Boone bringer Valkyrie this is the sets
version of Bane Slayer Angel
I don't know if it's as powerful as what
Bane Slayer wants was then
black Titan unfortunately the worst
Titan and the Titan cycle even though
it's a brand new one
agar the freezing Flame
Zada Zada hedron grinder
etched
Rowan's Talon oh nice
and oh nice brawl chief of compliant in
the kaladesh
Masterworks I believe it was called
bordering there actually again
surprisingly I don't have one of these
but now I do
and that is it what a really nice pack
as well
already last pack so far no Ragga band
pretty lucky though two free tours
skip through these guys
change the equation
we've got
battle of moraganda
if I'm pronouncing that right
really is this this is not Sarah's realm
is it really nice planes
we're already up first yes heck our
first Planeswalker so we've got
invasion of new forexia
X blue white
summon a bunch of knights
and then when we defeat invasion
we get to theory arakosa of zelphia this
this obviously goes straight into the
knights commander deck which I'm hoping
to pick up
sick Planeswalker can't complain
got another glistening Dawn I think I
think this is the third one we've opened
oh
uh shall I and haldar
I believe there's infinite combos with
this
I think this is in the quarter back up
as world deck
another it's just a regular tamarette in
the alternate art
em candy pride of ethemareth
this is again in the Halo artwork uh
Halo foiling very nice
oh wow sunfall this is the best new
wrath of God
excellent and the final card
nice sizen proverter perverta of Truth
this is such a gorgeous reprint on the
uh not reprint sorry new artwork in the
nice kamagawa neon kamagawa frame
again the text seems a little bit blurry
I don't know for you guys on camera I
think it looks fine but for me it looks
a little bit blurry
and is that it that is it
whoa
that's a pretty good collector box I'm
pretty soaked with that no serialized uh
cards but I mean we got our two prayer
tours which I can't really complain
about we gotta we got a foil Ragga van
yay I'm super stoked of opens this foil
Ragga van
hahaha anyways I hope you guys enjoyed I
hope you guys opened all the cards you
want to open
in the future
I'm just really excited let's quickly
look at this Hazard again
hope you guys have a wonderful night
thank you so much for your support of
the channel the last couple of days
really means a lot to me we're almost at
a thousand subscribers
thank you so much for watching
stay safe
and I'll see you guys next time